Lord if I was different  I'm excited to have a song with him I  mean I know he's eventually going to go  down in the Hall of Fame I sing Old Red  at my Show's acapella huge fan of him  and he's just a great dude so I'm very  happy that I have a song with him on my  album I'm a lifelong fan yes I am  after you know God's country came out it  sounded like right up his alley so I  sent it to him he got back to me I was  just crossing my fingers that he jumped  on it and he he did he kept his word  what if I was  age what if I was made for the light  with more rock inspired tracks on his  new album Kane hopes to bring in a new  crowd  definitely wanted it also to be guy  friendly so I feel like a lot of songs  that we had like we definitely had the  girl audience  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I wanted like the girls to be able to  play it and then you know some of their  dudes that think they're too cool to be  like okay I can listen to this you know  what I mean